Shh we're doing it live gamers last of
us gameplay live where's my GP ol how
you guys do it first of all this is a no
symptom I will not read donations
although I appreciate them thank you I
[Music]
want to be I don't attract too much from
the gameplay but I do want to interact
with you guys
and I'm sure you will tell me when I do
something horrific a wrong it's
everything okay it's just sound good
I'd hate for this to not work out we're
playing this we're doing it live man
this is weird I never done this can you
hear the gameplay you should be able to
yeah yeah it's a little old but thank
you see I know I know you guys too well
all right here we go you're again 1 & 2
yeah so oh I hear donations hold up
you want to see something spectacular
mom why things aren't you nothing is
that spectacular oh brother
come on stupid nothing really have you
seen the arrogance ass excuse me you're
gonna smell again
all right we're so happy yes watch part
1 yet thank you for joining part 2 if
that's the case Legends squeeze through
got some flammable liquid and that's
that big I like how it sounds like I'm
making money whenever I talk to someone
in this game a little looking hella
confused what happened to you Ellie used
to look cute
not that I care about anyone looking
cute because there's only one person in
the world that's Q me and my SIA Dan
Edgar now you think of this view huh
it's pretty nice okay yeah yeah this
route has its perks
so I've actually played this about ten
minutes I kinda have to restart for the
sake of the livestream so just you know
I'm not cheating okay
it's an all right view Ritz is supposed
to take case place I mean sorry dumb all
right guess we're leaving
what do you used to do this route with
Jesse Eugene right Oh Eugene who is
judean his Eevee Asian guy funny no it
was okay
okay I go thank you
Plus get out of way rewiring electronics
and stuff that's awkward we all be that
sharp seventy-three
do you like my headphones by the way
everything look good
better you tell me now say all good or
all epic so I know all right I'm not I'm
looking at the ground hey your backpacks
open how did she survive the apocalypse
I see a lot of ethics I'll take that
Ferb cool thanks for being here guys
appreciate you this is cool
excited soon what was this place you
used to be a radio tower and now it's a
collection for Maya what is this oh
that's was it clear the D looks like a
smiley face that's hilarious can they
have written something funny software
pretty encampment all clear e yen Dena
c'mere
so apparently we had a fight the day
before me and Dina but they still let us
out on a patrol together seems
irresponsible hey I'm just saying turn
up a heads our last stop take a look
okay where's the town I don't see it
there's the Traer with the big tower
thing Oh yep that's for the next one is
is this the town there's a ski lodge
guys this is a Interactive live stream
you can point it out for me now it's
this that Swiper Felix let's get back to
the horses back to your again let's go
gamers
don't look at me like that
all right I'm walking question were you
wearing those things I knew she was
judging me they're clean
no Justin oh it's a client rule you know
we're gonna kill infected not to look
fancy still look nice
thank you god damn
do I have to cook where am I supposed to
go Oh down here yeah yeah
I know I know cuz I'm pro gamer there
they are
look at those finances goddamn Oh
so we'll see amazing thing the view cuz
it wasn't that great I'm not gonna sit
here and lie to you guys okay I'm I'm
sorry I need to stop look at the check
because these things happen
am i stupid did the game bleach out Oh
it's telling me to jump sorry I'm bad
jump then I need more speed are you
serious uragan you're useless here we go
yeah told you I'm Pro told you bro look
anyone knows to follow her but I go this
way
Oh Eugene bed you no way come on you're
way too reckless look who's talking
look at this gorgeous
run something click are you wearing
boots today you know you're gonna die
ooh let me guess you're gonna kill me
poor shadowing mark my words gamers know
maybe it's war
damn Oh face hey should we check these
houses out seems quiet but hell yeah I
want supplies
get off me here again horses are the
best part of this game so far not gonna
lie what do you know about this place
just another evacuated neighborhood oh
really
infected almost never make it this far
hey we got pills I'll take a supplement
huh what do you guys think it's in them
xanax listen mode movement speed okay
know things what else we got
hey random mo in a drawer hell yeah what
I'm right here okay isn't it one of
those superhero cards you're all into
cuz I don't want it the hell is this
Tessa raised her that's the racer flip
it brains
he's got big brains he's villain or a
hero appearing one day from out of the
blue no one knows where or when this
mysterious transdimensional being where
this determined okay alright their
ability to move in and around four
dimensional space at will has turned the
tide in many battles though using his
power leaves them as weak and vulnerable
as a new board claiming to no have no
name that were bestowed the bestow of
the nickname Tess arrestor by society of
champions am i playing last summer's
here what is this
however some suspect has a peso rest
there is keeping their true I think I
can't read cuz it's all fate awaiting
this undiscovered identity every day I
read books okay shut up alright put it
back I don't want it
steena I get nervous when I read loud
okay it's different
what are you doing it in you I was
thinking of the inviting Jules oh yeah
that's better that's the right answer
good Ellie seems for no one what's Joel
into hentai uh Curtis and Viper - that's
the one that's been on my radar for a
while oh oh wow she sounds so interested
yeah you got cooked girl I'm not going
with you
I mean Joel no one else no one else the
temperature dropped aren't they wearing
a bit skinny clothing for living out in
this kind of weather as a Swedish person
this offends me okay I got a jump here
okay
watch this guy's watch the jump yeah oh
I did it I did it in fact it did this
how many you think it would take to
bring down a city your again look
they're on their own
hurry muslin I can tell long gun I like
are they calling it long gun I know that
long thing yeah hmm see she wants me to
go there but I'm I'm a sandwich I go
yeah I know how game design work
[ __ ] I hear some inside Oh Oh more
importantly how do we get in there
I see a bunch of different nations yeah
let's go it's zombie-killing time boys
this way
finally some gameplay that doesn't
involve jumping horses should I have it
all around you sleep now right
think how much you gotta suck to die as
a zombie you're Katie's like it's - to
[ __ ] cringe dude leg let's see if we
can get around at the back of this
supermarket good idea
big brain you got big brain found that
big brain how do I stand up I keep
forgetting I mean I know Bill's here
animal here toilet here [ __ ] stain here
this is not the door okay you're welcome
what's the point of doing this
it was just extra bonus yeah yeah hold
it down yeah
are - yeah I punch you I stab alright
that worked that well yeah yeah nice
throw by the way thanks the way we came
in was bear has it been laid by the way
shouldn't be a bit delayed I think about
it yeah that's a good question what's
the most infected you've ever taken down
on Patrol
let me know if it's delayed god I can't
talk then when I had with Joel your so
ago it was like it doesn't you me should
be like a lamb don't look like it is I
mean it will get you a new personal
record today looks good is it alright
I'll go with it you know what let me
record it and then if it's a problem I
can just reload it cool cuz I'm just
realizing I'm commentating I should be
it should be like half a second delay
probably and that's why you haven't
noticed it yet but i could be wrong i
don't mean the chat i mean the gameplay
it's alright it just hit me I'm like oh
yeah it's too late alright are we
looking for we definitely heard more
zombies in here
oh my god so awkward oh I see it it was
the right where we came big brain
yeah shown what they did you sleep down
yeah
totally plain damn what the hell is that
twitching stay dead [ __ ] ooh
what happened your nose forgot to wear
Sun Tan screen Sun cream English it's my
second language
have some patience they looted the ball
I'm gonna flip us okay let's be careful
here
yeah get thick I think they saw me
now we're okay alright so how many those
don't worry guys I'm a pro gamer are
they seeing me or they see me oh my god
I'm gonna die
are you serious where the [ __ ] did they
come from my double strike FA hi guys
and that's how that's done ya hear that
face le she's a psychopath
alright that went just as planned I
think that went pretty good good thing I
am having stealth skills sorry I'll try
and self more that was a bit failing
yeah looks like it
we've still got to get the ones in the
supermarket
let's keep circling the pills man Kavya
way in
I'll find it okay so if we have to go
through here they must be here somewhere
yeah found it yeah over the truck I miss
em Oh Oh God
see this is why this is why I'm
streaming cannot go out of ammo coming
who had the ammo huh who had the ammo
this is important if you mission one
thing no one's ever gonna let it go and
it will what the [ __ ]
scared me dude where I'll [ __ ] it it
won't matter weird this early in the
game alright lift me up [ __ ]
come on yeah I wear my flashlight out
door you guys got a problem with it
there's a hole in the roof over there
pretty good thanks
look see all right
let's figure out how to get in there Oh
green beans market how do we get in
there duh buh duh buh duh printed back
what is this what's she doing you're not
gonna be able to lift that you're not
Debbie or whatever her name is
yeah her name is Debbie now it was on
the table
god damn it gameplay ruined thought
maybe we get lucky try not being so oh I
got it I got it I got it I got it oh I
got I got it I got it I got it I got it
don't worry guys I got it I got it
how am I supposed to go don't look so
clueless
am i stupid yes
maybe through here where oh my god I
don't see it Jesus Christ
shut up don't ever do that again
you heard it three seconds early see I
think there is a bit of delay let me see
if I can just fix that one second
hey-ho oh dude big brain
I honestly my brain is so large
sometimes it hurts fixed it live
[ __ ] big brain sorry for everyone
thanks for waiting okay that should I
should have fixed that if anything I
don't need a hint [ __ ] off
thank you for your gold and patients
appreciate ya I mean if you watch me you
probably have already shut up shut up
I'm looking for pills I'm busy ooh
[Music]
ma'am I'm sorry to God for what I did I
wasn't going to hurt ya I didn't want
anything from your store except for the
drugs your husband came at me what
choice did I have
my lil sister stopped feeling her feet I
needed the insulin everyone is hoarding
this stuff what choice did I have
I hope he survives I'm sorry
I'm not I took the pills didn't even
hesitate got anything here alright how
we're looking now this is still good say
yes or no duck duck yeah nice we got
some herbs Inez watch this huh whoa all
right this way I'll take it I don't
trust you but I'll take it
god damn she just loves to jump in
without checking first [ __ ] if I was at
pocalypse I'd be 10 times better than
this
you know I check all of those drawers I
have already been working on here gross
margins gross profit expenses do we need
a website update absolutely not I don't
think get the [ __ ] out of my way eat the
soup dude as soon as I find the soup I'm
gonna eat it a couple of rags here fix
yourself up hey we get the craft yeah I
hit this and then I hit the craft and
bing bang Bing Bing bong
we made us a tab on I said that only
because it rhymed just so we're clear
okay hold to heal
I hit the right button I bit I a partner
all right nice she spores in their masks
on got it
I feel like I got to catch myself making
dumb jokes especially if it's a lie I
don't have to shoot you in the face this
week yeah
all these spores mean they've been here
for a while
keep your eyes peeled or infected yep I
got some cleaning stuff
very nice I don't know I think we're
above it
guess it's of our crime scene later
ground floor squeeze through ah employee
of market the month with a great market
they all died F's in the chat hey hey
hey we got a safe
those spoilers in the comments boys what
we got another note
yo Kristin let the real [ __ ] in the safe
foyer combo is the date of my good boy
got Employee of the Month
don't [ __ ] sell or give them an away
that's for your back alright feel better
my good boys at the dog Jesus yeah I
meant to do that
dog employee oh my god his employee of
the month that's a win that's a huge win
July 13 get out my way
I miss Joel already what is this thing
the rider was a gangster now the
question is is it 13 mm I'm someone I
use putting in put on the circular
button oh god what am i doing oh god
what am i doing go back [ __ ] go back
what month is July salmon right okay
let's do this hey I'm Swedish it's not
my fault my brain doesn't work or does
it or does it work yo [ __ ] joint
Kepley I fixed that [ __ ] delay issue
by myself didn't have to watch some 13
year old on YouTube explaining it to me
extremely slowly
alright let's kill some zombies that's
all I want
you did not see if anything was there le
come boy
alright alright
house quality I got way better internet
here it's quite nice shouldn't be 60fps
you know I'm all about quality that's
the one my number one thing is I know
you guys appreciate a good quality
youtuber like myself Phil's here get me
craft anything now we can increase our
listen mode yeah one I big blob yeah she
do not hesitate to shove down 30 pills
look up look up
I told he'll finish everything he did
I won't look away everyone look away
okay I think I can use my flashlight as
a blind right yeah you guys scared all
right just so we're clear if you see any
titties just look away that those are
the rules
all right no titty let's not walk on
that bottle yeah no titty get out of my
get out of me I'm looking away I'm
looking away yeah nailed it
I'm literally shaking I know
hi I think she hurt me
oh wow
how did she hear me was i walking cringe
my Ben whoops
alright I'll just do this again in front
of everyone
that's what I want it right now my bad
sir deafs please put in the chat why I'm
not even [ __ ] walking dude this is
slow enough I walked it fast my bad if
there's anything I know about this game
just say oh my god
see I can't really I'll just stop
walking with a click dude look at her
feet though I think she has an old fence
problem is when I'm live singing I have
no patience but this game seems more
like if you want to take your time I
hope people won't be too pissed on
streaming this but it feels more fun I
[Applause]
never done this before
[Music]
live playthrough feels very modern
alright let's walk slow this time yeah
easy use the bottle we're not just the
aggravate them blind [ __ ] make
my skin crawl
okay who's the bigot now Ellie you got a
problem with blind people now sheesh
sheesh Louise doctor snake and fine
would not have a problem at night any
loot there we go
bro game booth right here
taking your time there yeah I'll make it
available for everyone for sure it
wouldn't feel right
[Music]
I'll make you a present
I'll take a prison I'll take some
alcohol and I'll take doctor token I
would take that home
would that be good decoy time that you
know zombie apocalypse it's always be
like breath I should make me a cocktail
here Thanks
careful with that can I make one nope I
miss a rag someone yeah whoa
12 pills goddamn some pills are
definitely worth it then to try and find
it yeah we got two cocktails
let's go yeah my wait Deena Deena
I don't wanna be yeah all right well
they actually felt this oh wow yeah
hey you have blood on him French the
audio is great if you guys are listening
with headphones they're clicking it's so
creepy
so these ones don't hear as well or I
[Applause]
think I'm pissing up the clicker web eh
God is this creepy
I saw the towel I didn't want to took it
oh god this will be a nightmare if we
met oh no I'm sorry
Oh
mr. Bo ssam B I thought they were blind
and I wasn't moving I'm confused can
someone explain what just happened
[Applause]
Sarah that's that does not count
you didn't even see the zombie French no
I don't know I don't know which buttons
reloads and I'm too scared of clicking
someone tell me which bunny Lotus
instead of saying real Evan
yeah but the runners didn't see me I was
hidden I know the runners aren't blind I
[Applause]
see where this pitch goes I'm gonna
follow her okay that was not one thing
[Applause]
hopefully no one sees those eyes
the shoot button to reload thanks guys
shut up shut up shut up [ __ ] trolls
dude I am listening to your [ __ ]
[Applause]
so she's not supposed to see me stop
screaming so much it's scaring me
is it only the clickers left nope okay I
think I know how she walks she was
turning around here was it because I
wasn't close standing there oh god can I
make it can I make it oh God
you bad baby yeah oh look away titties
look away look away
[Music]
wait the shoot bun is the actual reload
I'll try that I'll try it I'll try it
once we're done can I get this guy
how does she walk how you doing there
you having a bad day let's have a Pepsi
minute
all right so nice somehow I piss them
off I don't understand I didn't see the
black guy okay then let me where was he
did yes all right throw the bottle okay
instantly sees me through their cover
all right that's cool I'm not even mad
[Music]
okay fish hold up where need to take
this [ __ ] out and then we're good cheap
don't turn around
do not touch stop moving and don't turn
around think we need a face mommy Modi
shut up hahaha what what you didn't see
oh they were in the other room I think
oh my god you were right any still
moving you do that you do reload with
art - that's funny I'm impressed with us
I'm not it's my first playthrough I'm
not a Zoomer my reflexes are off by at
least as much as delayed this webcam has
that's good agreed
I brought brick good old brick he'll be
with me brick doesn't criticize my
gameplay yeah yeah I found it found the
way out oh wait nevermind that was a
joke it was a joke I'm full of bottles
apparently damn no I don't I don't see a
way out to you
jump
yeah he didn't say sick of dying he
meant say I'm sick of being so good
thank you yeah what are you doing dude
they got bread
hold up I shouldn't be wearing these
like razor please don't have any other
headphones right now that has the okay
here we found the way out you're welcome
it's fun though
I'm having a lot of fun here's what
we're gonna do you're just gonna hurl me
up through that hole in the roof easy
okay
do I look like Debbie to you I can't do
that Hey look cable here two girls and a
long object comes to the rescue
I'll let you figure out the rest best
hilarious joke folks are you 12 yes I am
thank you don't list the delivery on
that tear I'm sorry all right what do I
do
yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah I would have
said yeah man [ __ ] yeah yeah you go
first okay it's safe trust me like these
headphones thank you it's Marcia
I threw away my 3.5 cable lute I don't
see any [ __ ] loo all right let's do a
quick rundown so chat will calm down
okay okay there was loot my bad then I
suppose my bad I was about to make fun
of you for not being any loo I could not
have continued this playthrough without
that rank what else do we have
ooh 220 that's a great price all right
that's the very much time what the [ __ ]
I missed this best item in the game now
I feel really stupid for missing it
gee thanks guys
rag gang never miss a rag gang
damn it's getting windy
oh she said you couldn't yeah we
shouldn't probably not head out jörgen
smegging I'm sorry it's gotta be
freezing for you god that's okay watch
these jump guys yeah
first trying already for number two yeah
first struck she jumped in
[Music]
oh yeah put on a hoodie oh you're
against cold we can't run fast
getting worse I don't like this
Oh
Jesus
yeah run away a bit more well your G
says Jurgen is struggling here
[ __ ] is wrong with you demon oh great no
tracks where the [ __ ] did she go oh my
god
[Music]
oh my god I'm dead vena killed me thanks
Ally
she probably went to the house this
could be it
she's probably cooking up some power
you know
Oh cancel Venus wait where are we going
don't ask me if I don't find which I
haven't thank you
I know it's kind of cool that they ride
in with the horses but shouldn't they
check that it's a first I don't know why
this things bother me see I would have
checked the place before I closed the
door and I'm saying this is me give him
a smack down all right let's see what
books they got let's make sure it's
clear we have we have wanted history
wanted history again wanted history
again whatever this is
they're four times disruption of bees
yeah who knows without me the Virgin man
it's you guys I don't know you were in
here Wow smiles for society and not so
it's no stake
oh it's streak [ __ ] Desert Gold I would
have picked a steak book you guys look
for rags and [ __ ] I want to see what
books they got kawaii I'm kidding it's
Hawaii wide a wide range of selection of
books really I'm impressed
pull the bottle son doesn't feel like
anyone's been here in a while a virgin
man it's a classic it's about a man that
placed too much video games and he still
sucks at it
I gotta see what's back there I got this
you see that [ __ ] that works that's
funny
whoa whoa booth yeah speaking of which
do we have enough there we can upgrade
yeah we do yeah nobody else would take
her [ __ ] but why would he hide it from
me cuz he doesn't like you
yeah please check before No all right
definitely Eugene's place I rotate it
flip it he was a Firefly
yes Tommy good old Tommy I had no idea
yeah I got this real dark [ __ ] take all
the books and create a tunnel library
will have a checkpoint at Denver qz
killed three soldiers civilians not epic
Jesus he also told me that he and Tommy
slow tortured some big federal general
Jesus I I don't buy Tommy doing that
though he could do worse what do you
mean yeah what do you mean you and Joel
did a lot to survive after the outbreak
is he the guy from the beginning seen
the other guy that Joel was talking to
oh my god boys Playstation
we got uncharted 3 to Jack and Dexter -
what's that underneath it nice for those
who don't know Naughty Dog the
developers made those games they make
epic games except this one apparently
everyone hates it already even though
they haven't played it yet but I want to
see if it's good ok it's Tommy and
Eugene baby's here
fights heaters
Eugene I'm begging you to come home the
Firefly want to save the world I say let
them let them go after the military the
politicians let them develop a vaccine
to save mankind maybe one day we'll use
will cure will her Oh Monday will live
to see the fruits of their fantasies
until then I have to put our daughter
first the fire facts will be fine
without you my daughter once she keeps
asking me when you're coming here I
can't lie to her anymore I miss you but
I don't know how much more I can of this
I can take come home please I love you
okay
work on your handwriting alright it's
supposed to say we'll live
can't [ __ ] read am I wrong or am i
double right yes nice bumpy yes
impressive work Benjy Jean
but you could mod your gun with this
gear well don't mind if I do
so we can upgrade our long or as short
feet probably start with our short thing
fire rate stability accuracy or magazine
capacity
let's do fire rate first that's right
there it feels like what they wanted to
do upgrade soup alright thank you for
your contribution yeah this'll work can
I upgrade anything else oh I have a ten
twenty fifty got it shoots Dina it works
oh hello you think I'd a heater and [ __ ]
bring that thang le look at the floor
mmm there's more stuff down there you
see you way down not here
yes hey a giraffe
she dropped all she drew the giraffe
epic see I was wondering where they
gonna do that I was wondering when
they're gonna draw the giraffe there it
is do you know if I was gonna go to the
dance and she touched my arm I'm so
delusional don't be an idiot
she's she's alive
she's lived she's oh she's like that
with everybody
don't [ __ ] up your friendship don't [ __ ]
up your friendship don't lock up your
friendship then I was crazy I just
scared
related anchors what's judean in touch
with other fireflies did he hear about
me and Joel no he would have said
something I don't know
joel has a tendency of not being too
upfront Jesus let's keep it off
oh god this is another yeah we got
Lauren for Celt Wow Lauren from cult
born with brilliant mind but humbled by
numerous physical ailments big brain
tiny hair Lauren for cult spent his
Lauren it's a guy named in hospitals are
earning his MD PhD at age fifteen damn
he developed a cure for his rare genetic
disease but he couldn't cure his
baldness he could save everyone but
himself the patterns for which made him
a multi millionaire overnight within a
few short years he turned millions into
billions given him the capital to build
SciTech empire Spock and free reign to
pursue knowledge and progress at any
cost
except his hair rumors circulate that
spark has developed methods to infuse
new bones with specific superpowers but
for called has an ID is ridiculous
claims 100% villain I trust him I trust
anyone that's bald what the [ __ ] is that
oh hey I saw something else but I won't
say what I saw let's just keep moving
quick
got something here come on his chef
basis what's he got down here and I lost
a penny a sex den hey we got three more
copies of one that history on the right
hell yeah it was worried they didn't
have enough with us it's probably just
like a giant TV he didn't want to share
I'm eighty percent certain all right if
you're that sure oh my god that's a lot
of weed that's a lot of dead weed I've
seen the chat boys a lot I've seen the
chat 50,000 used to live here
what is this I don't know what this is
what this this thing eh call one of the
wolf smash Brandis couch or this is porn
interesting taste you Dean
smash smash brandy couch oh wow what a
joke
hey but it back but it back Ellie you
could not do that but oh there we go
you think it's still good look away
everyone looks away no bad don't do this
find out you having a hard time don't
know I got it [ __ ] but give me that
oh yeah like you're gonna get it okay
yeah just smash it [ __ ] it
oh no what the [ __ ] is wrong with you I
got it open didn't I
it smells good everyone look away please
no no when we struck here a while all
right I'm serious
totally trapped Naughty Dog is more than
naughty huh sex jokes weed what's next
huh oh no oh no not that look no no no
can you scale of one to ten zero one
being like absolute trash Zehra and ten
being oh my faltering how would you rate
our kiss from last night I said Sarah
didn't I why are we still talking about
this
you said it was a mistake did I say that
what are you doing I asked you to read
our kiss unbelievable
I give it a six a six Wow like a solid
six okay there are a lot of people
around
yeah but six Oh what I mean now I really
want to know how you'd read it I said
Sarah come on ice is so awkward oh no
cuz i know cuz i you know have you met
you because i know you make me want to
go back outside don't stop i if you're
under the age of twelve go
don't look Chris oh my god oh oh why
they really go for it
[Music]
still zero oh no oh we're back with
Debbie I forgot a name what is their
actual name Oh God all right it's all
good I just said pick it slow [ __ ] [ __ ]
are they fighting sorry I got it listen
okay we got a bunch of them over there
oh god do they see me in their Blizzard
they must serve this is fine this is
fine
I think I'm supposed to run
well this is very stressful
don't worry I know just the spot guys I
know just the spot and we'll run through
here not in the water
okay we go [ __ ]
zombies can't stand water fingers it's
going the ices okay let me run alright
we'll go here yeah yeah yeah nice jump
I shouldn't have jumped that way oh [ __ ]
me there's a lot of things
get up [ __ ] get up huh God he stresses
me out
mm-hmm I'm safe [ __ ] me are you serious
where do I go I can't think straight
okay all right now now I'm pissed
where do I go there's a door there fine
bien bien okay bien this game really
once heard a die up sure gone up I
didn't see it it felt like I was
supposed to go here
Oh through here up was not correct I
don't know why I miss
brain so small
can do this some other time for better
weather now my mother
she took her that's nothing
[Applause]
is that Joel its Joe
okay I was I was gonna go there anyway
Papa Joel okay Papa Joe be the best no
matter it does is where we go got a
better idea
hey you got a good yeah I'm not I'm
really not I'm Jesus come back with a
cleanup crew
[Music]
all right here we go we're coming for
DHS over here
I forget that it's automatic I feel like
I'm nuclear quick this yeah double Hey
yeah do I have any mercy thank you
I can't pull up the mayor
hey girl I'll help
push it up under the car
I know what the [ __ ] do you come from
beach it's hard to aim I have I I have
plenty I have plenty of ammo I don't say
okay let's just get real here I'm very
bad at this game kind of is that I'm
sorry all right watch this
now from that one I'm ashamed of the
minis
all right all right coming out I want
it's a nice all right you understand
I'm not [ __ ] with it yo you get yo
can you
I got your pen he said help me I'm
playing the hardest difficulty that's
why I'm struggling a little
just a little bit still struggling a
little bit gave me all the [ __ ] ammo
I'll save Dan before the
oh my god
it's a one shot to the knees that's how
we're gonna do this we just did one shot
one shot
one shut all the clickers names oh just
right in the need his planners yeah yeah
I keep out of the [ __ ] way here
action all right knee and then
I'll listen pick they're coming me
there we go that's how is the Jesus all
right then dad Vanilli zero this that's
not bad
alright I find the new strategy this is
to work you're doing justice by letting
her die chief why does everyone hate
it's a nice
very nice hey I'm Tommy that's Joe
what's your name Abby Abby Abby we
cannot stay here
think make it all that my friends are at
a mansion story it's Vince didn't we
have the whole perimeter ski Sibbald
I'll get the door come on
hey horses
holy [ __ ] that was cool
that's the fun part and it's cool to
nail it like first try being so
intuitive and just like picking up the
game it quiet
oh my what the [ __ ] I'm eating nothing
wrong to eat your donors are like oh how
did you get the scar I was just already
[Laughter]
why is it so funny okay man let me make
sense the ad pocalypse you're not gonna
bother by shaving your armpit it makes
total sense
[Music]
Dakara bite mark right here I got jumped
by and infected when I was 14 and it
turns out I'm immune so it heals with a
ring of [ __ ] up teeth marks and cysts
and I'll [ __ ] you what hey I told you a
real [ __ ] story
tell you a real [ __ ] story oh you
want a bite mark sound it sounded like
it clicker that you hear that Jesse just
stay there okay Oh his name is Jesse
you're supposed to be on patrol there's
a blizzard outside is that weed why are
you here
people are counting on you you get that
what we do matters well then why aren't
you want the [ __ ] lookout because
Tommy and Joel didn't show up uh-oh what
do you mean we waited for them for an
hour I was looking for their horses when
I saw lights maybe they just went back
to town without being replaced no way
how much of the region have you covered
I'm not sure then we split up go at it
from different sides we can cover the
whole thing in a few hours I don't like
you dragging so low we don't know what's
out there exactly what they need help
okay I'll head west Dina can take south
and you come from the east but be smart
about again ya big brain
[Music]
I think that bees in that bad of a
character no everyone hates us so much
police is something different
[Applause]
don't see it remains to be seen
yeah bar
and there are effective
[Music]
you'll find out guys so spoiling it
differently I know that's not a spoiler
but
just for the record
[Music]
how do you get some buffed up what kind
of workout equipment do they have an
apocalypse huh we're good thanks yeah I
guess it makes sense to get juiced up
for the apocalypse
I don't like her though she's hiding
something when it presents muscle agrees
been here yesterday yes yep what are
y'all doing up this way just passing
through
you two live nearby we do a few hours
down the hill y'all should come back
with him to restock before we head out
appreciate it
I'm Mellie Tommy this is my brother Joe
oh he's the guy they were looking for
like you heard was her soon cuz they
have oh wow what the [ __ ] I understand
now [ __ ] you see save your life [ __ ]
get out that hurt my legs yes Debbie
[Music]
well you say with her speech you got
rehearsal goddamn some badass tourniquet
is like Turney crit what does that make
what does that mean that means twisting
it oh you know what that [ __ ] is
happening I gave her the benefit of the
[ __ ] doubt what in the [ __ ] is this
Oh God don't you [ __ ] know no clear
out that [ __ ] is happening right now
stupid old man
you don't get to rush this Jesus Christ
it's to stop the bleeding
oh I see so we can torture him what's up
what is wrong with her
I don't understand why people don't like
her I saw some golf Commons I just heard
something oh you like playing golf I'm
like why am I getting raided by someone
now I get it
now I get it Oh God Joe Oh God
don't jump there Jesus you're not Debbie
that became John okay all right I'm
gonna avoid chatting out for a minute I
don't want any I mean I if you if you
write as well that you will get either
banned or timed out so it you don't
matter but getting safe it just ain't
safe this mirror it looks like something
in the snow hair like a little fairy but
it's probably just a little light glitch
yeah can I squeeze three great Ellie's
just in time for the action
Joel no no are they left the window open
bunch of dummy brainers oh god alright
hurry I [ __ ] shoot all of them oh god
where they go are they in the basement
this is the front door isn't it no Jay
thanks the [ __ ] what's going on
why aren't you posted up outside what do
you think anyone who's gonna show up the
hell did you expect we got to get out of
here for the whole town's on top of us
Yeah right end it oh my god no you're
[ __ ] get up oh please stop this
breaks my heart
[Music]
I don't even got started we barely
played anything
[Music]
understand
[Applause]
Oh
but
[Applause]
oh my god I [ __ ] kill Ellie next what
the [ __ ] is going on here I got I got so
many questions
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Music]
why am I so butthurt this is like it
happened right away we've barely gotten
started on the game and they just killed
Joel why why can they wait at least if
they wanted to kill up the character I
made you a sandwich sorry about your
dead dad hey hey
they let her go Joel was like a father
to me let's sit down please
for real it was such a great character
it was so fun
their interaction that was what made the
game good what and now I'm no it's like
this everything makes sense now
oh the Debbie hey Marie wants to make
sure you're eating she can't stop us
so the point of the game is revenge then
they have the guys that we would need to
do this smart we believe in Jackson
vulnerable so they just get to get away
with this nobody wants that yeah but
that's what's happening what if we get
hit by hunters again is this you talking
or is this her it's a valid point if it
were you or me Joel would be halfway to
Seattle already no he wouldn't
absolutely [ __ ] would be well we
don't even know for certain that they're
from Seattle Washington Liberation Front
that's what you said was on those
patches what if they still knows jacket
that's that's WLF move what are you
doing yeah you know what that's a nice
couch looks either cuz I'm late tomorrow
and if you want to come with me great
you have no idea what you're walking
into it looks soft you don't know how
large that group is how armed I don't
care you can't talk me out of this
I'm telling it I'm trying to think about
what they're doing with it but I just I
don't it just seems so hey to talk to
Maria okay I've got to be some folks you
can spare she won't budge better be able
to kill Debbie fine golf club with the
driver no with a putt one day please
fine it's like a movie having a
different tone for the trailer
except you waited seven years for the
movie to come out oh god I don't want to
judge the game before I played it yet I
mean maybe there's some twists and turns
who knows clearly there's twists but
it's like this is why I don't get hyped
for games it's just not worth a man if
you're joining the stream now nothing
happened just leave just leave us
nothing happened you'd be happier if you
left not knowing oh god we suffering
gang so I look away quick Oh No now look
away quick look away quick oh God
keep looking away
[Music]
that's a thumbnail those spoilers that's
a thumbnail of the video
[Music]
hey at least we have Deena right yeah
it's all good yeah all right
you can keep watching now let's say
we're at the graveyard for no reason I
know that we couldn't get to the horses
Oh looks like they got the horses too
it's the worst day of my life Tommy I'll
figure something else out on the way car
a horse or something
okay
this makes getting to Seattle a lot
harder man it's gonna be harder they can
still change your mind you know I know
what would have been a better story any
you go I guess so I alright thanks for
watching last of us to gameplay it's
been a crazy journey
wow what a sad ending you need to get
your backpack I hid it by the East gates
I figured we'd wanna slip out that way
let's at his house don't you dare shoot
the bunny Ellie
don't you dare shoot the bunny no more
killing
hmm hey what do you need I can go get it
well it happened because the YouTuber
Bank you understand this right
DNA is complicit I'm ok if Dina wasn't
in the game Joel would be aligned think
about that Hey look a wooden fish all I
got done here Thanks
no PlayStation cringe Oh
why the [ __ ] am I reading this Dino I
guess I was a good day
this is a reference to the first game
because I don't does he have that movie
we're gonna watch a movie here oh he's
got Moby Dick what a legend can't read
the other ones dead should then alive
they should just call it dead I remember
the voice actor for Joel actually
tweeting out something about the game
having an open mind so I'm trying to
have an open mind it's just really hard
right now he clearly was trying to warn
us he was trying to tell us what are you
drawing out our Islands and now thanks
Ellie wait wait wait there was others my
mouth tastes like Aaron rooms break open
as I sing you were the soft twang of
Nilan a smell of wood oil fretful guitar
strings with iron sound brighter they
mistook your resonance and left me with
rust all I had
but lat I haven't our last conversation
looping like a chord progression
harmonies in blood tell me said her name
was Abby Abby gonna die Wow
vengeance justice for Joel
justice justice for Joel think about it
this way think how sweet it's gonna be
to kill Debbie Debbie Debbie daddy
no look what a nice place that [ __ ]
had huh how am I supposed to do here sir
I didn't listen dude's got a picture of
a horse
what a loser all right let's check in
here
I saw something he had so many guitars
what took him so long oh he makes his
own geesh all the promises that sundown
I meant them like the rest clean your
nails sheesh Dave
did he really liked horses he carved
that [ __ ] damn he card all this [ __ ]
damn what a legend just killed off huh
like bang just like that fool all not
the clothes not the smell
the lost of us - I thought they were
gonna kill Ellie for a while I'm not
even joking it's like well anything can
happen now this is a good thing you know
in a way but that's his first daughter
you sometimes you know it's been a rough
year this was not what I wanted this
should have delayed the game another
year
then that's a gun that what we came for
that's a mail piece young gravy salt
young everything okay
all that good [ __ ] all right I'm going
down 20 20 you think it can't get worse
and then this happened I say sad noises
oh she better wear that watch when
getting revenge yes Maria I'm headed to
Seattle I wish I could let it go but I
can't I have to bring these people to
justice are we read this
Earl he's gonna try to come after me but
stop now we didn't take her guns locked
up the horses
maybe lock her up buy me some time so I
can end this love you always
Tommy he's gonna get himself killed
he should have taken me with him oh you
should have given us a group to go after
those [ __ ] wish I could you guys try
to lock me up I'd prefer that you stay
that's not gonna [ __ ] happen fur that
you stay but I know you better you going
with her better so you're just gonna
sneak out of here hmm
yeah on foot yeah
give me your again and summer again at
least I told the stable to let you out
with your horse grab some ammo - thanks
mom
Thank You Maria
just died do me a favor bring men
dumbass husband home on my piece please
of course all right
get going you're you're losing light I
don't I'm so I'm so n just bummed out I
know that's the mood of the game right
now I just want to get back into
something else something else right now
don't want to don't want the shitty mood
anymore
you know last was one was filled with
excitement from the top it was like what
we're going on this [ __ ] what's gonna
happen now is I just okay so we're in
Seattle it's all right Joe Abbey with
the revolver hell yeah Joe couldn't get
to his gun jeez are you scared
whoa look how amazing this game looks
how old are you fourteen how old were
you when you first killed someone we
talking affected no fully conscious non
fungal person ten Wow what happened I
was coming at my mom I stabbed him it
looks incredible I'm just gonna focus on
that pretty baby I think that's the way
to get through this
so how lost are we little that's that's
the goal right now those crazy cannibals
you said you and Joel ran into they came
after you guys once maybe these wo lufs
are connected to them no
didn't seem like the same group maybe
those black market smugglers back in
Boston
do not joel crossed a lot of people I
don't see the point
I'm guessing okay at least until we find
out more information is that a [ __ ]
squirrel hell yeah I'm gonna kill that
next huh
I'm just gonna kill a squirrel right in
front of me the one thing I love so far
I gotta say the story feels a bit like a
written by a I'll keep it to myself for
now I'm it just everything is so great
about the game it looks good it feels
good and then it's like oh but this is
the story okay I need to stop moping
about it maybe it gets better who knows
maybe denied epic who knows who knows
yes
yeah this is epic yeah this is good yeah
I like this yeah I mean the game has
[ __ ] ten ratings by every company
ever
alright there has to be a good gaming
here
it can't be that big of a deal it's just
okay it's okay all right sorry was I
supposed to do
I was listening my bad the cars here
let's check them out then I guess hey we
can drive so there's a station here
that's kind of hard to believe how long
has it been it's cool to just look
around I almost want this to be in first
person just look so mesmerizing I said I
seem weight is supposed to be on the
horse
then we come from there but literally
came from there I'm walking in circles
I'm sorry but where am I supposed to go
we literally came from here
confuse definitely not here right oh it
was okay sorry my bad
I look so dark whoa look at this
guess I was wrong it turns out you do
know where you're going yeah of course I
know where I'm going
whoa holy [ __ ] dude
look how this looks like I never seen a
game like this that's another game that
looks this good grass looks a bit off
though not gonna lie look better in the
jungle alright let's jump Road just
collapsed that's cool it happens
this looks very awkward I was looking at
the waterfall
sure seems quiet uncharted me to the
chat think about how well are they still
making Uncharted games wasn't it the
last one Oh scares me
well graphics get it's a 10 out of me
and for me at least
okay set the koozie yep watch the high
spots what was this originally like a
dam what is that
Oh pop that DHL truck it is alright I
need to kill something
alright you understand something needs
to die really face she's like a YouTube
comments I don't [ __ ] know where
you're talking about what cranks let's
check the Sun when you get to the gate
look for soldier named Karen tell him I
sent you
then give him that kilo and he'll get
you in side the ball good luck
I'll give him a kilo I'm pills cocaine
in the drawer
alright that's cool more cocaine and
Android that's cool you do you go
we got a Matt um Seattle so where are we
now
doesn't say let's put this [ __ ] away
anything good in there I'm mad found an
old tourist map Oh give me something
game gave me something all right those
are crack in the wall she said anybody
can climb just climb these no problem
throw a rope up there maybe I supposed
to find a rope there's like there's
nothing here but I'm gonna check it out
anyway yeah
how you doing here against Merrigan good
the recent night I play all right it's
gotta be something climbing this thing
yeah I see it now
three jump down here yeah drop down
anything cells soldiers have them in
Boston - Ellie what about this good bed
been here feet are on more steroids
until she pops oh she found something in
my bed
and literally did not need to climb it
where did she go goddamnit where'd she
go
I'm not wearing my headphones fine don't
mind if I do oh this is okay you better
have watched part one before you check
out the livestream come on guys
there we go big brain Deena
help me up here okay I'm not crying I'm
not crying shut up
I'll keep an eye out just see if you can
get the gate open from the other side
sounds good eep-eep eep-eep eep-eep
I'm pretending like nothing bad happened
bad about ever beat about exe you're
good from here and you again hey this is
cool
damn she looks pissed so now haven't
gotten over it huh cringe balance you
know what that's for the better
what the [ __ ] let's do that again
game can end a one-man we're doing like
this Wow what happened am I not supposed
to go there I was supposed to go here
okay my god this is a tough one nailed
it just like I always do so that's so
far if you watching the playthrough oh
you're not swinging up that flag forget
about it
yeah woah mention like another game with
these graphics one of my favorite
atmospheric games was Mirror's Edge the
first one second one wasn't as good whoa
imagine Matic for these graphics that we
say that's what I want all that I want
thank you game broke my legs things what
the [ __ ] I should slip this is me when I
see Debbie [ __ ] locked
well let me use my psychic powers got a
heat up the generator okay how do I get
you power she being smart with me just
plug in there all right let's grab this
boss boss well well well Oh miss
something what is this West okay I
wonder when this was written
okay so we're gonna enter the passcode
and it's one of these north gate
east-west OVA there's a flip
got a big operation coming up at and
Isaac wants to us to scavenge any
remaining supplies from downtown take
any gas from the courthouse base that's
something mmm sure is cleared zones not
many someone said oh cocaine more
cocaine do I keep that note I didn't see
if I grabbed it I think I did
that's a generator
oh forget to do the pulley thing nailed
it nailed it nailed it yes
that would carry the peepee huh
nice she dropped it that's got call a
little wonky but kinda cool okay you
never walk so slowly
are you not gonna pull that open I'd
have to press a button
I had to press a button
she's on there okay well I guess I have
to cut mine if it was Joel okay hey my
god everything okay what was that sound
I got that gate open got to figure out
this one now well we believe in you
Thanks can they have like a Oh Debbie's
bad we need to get her and still keep
Jolla line when they justify wouldn't
change anything then they can explore
the whole concept that the game ended on
with the why Joel was an upfront with
her have this really emotional
conclusion to it and then maybe kill
Joel in like the third one just thought
that popped in my head I grabbed
blankets for now instead let's get D to
this is this is not working at all
whatever checked
and soon this lock
phaedra
I'll put you to the benya it's juice
meaty we're all bummed bum gang Bund out
gang look at it [ __ ] do we looking
through how's it going
Oh goddammit SS if things couldn't get
any worse
oh my god no I've had it
guess we're gonna toss it over yes don't
get stuck in it Oh God
are you [ __ ] kidding me okay it's
fine oh my god
oh walkie but it works
Oh perfect length okay
and now we can do something like opening
the gate for the lazy [ __ ] see
Joel would have done this for us and
we'd be like gee thank alright what's
the passcode
I remember one the main gate password no
one knows it alright
I remember this one that's not what I
meant
oh my god I'm so not used to like X
being back it feels so unintuitive
action before word I have to enter a
random now what am I missing guys 6 9 4
I'll try it ok ok ok
so Chris Lachman wrote zero five one two
if Chris Lachman is wrong [ __ ] sake
oh there's a back one Chris Locke men's
penis will chop chop oh my god it's so
wonky I swear to God
I do that wrong tonight look at that yes
oh yes grace my man I'd never doubted
you
haven't kid you almost killed yoga you
crazy [ __ ] now what I found a note back
there do we get to kill something soon
yes please funny they got sucky night so
we find it hopefully we find our first
WLF get them to talk let's do it
what's what's the lacking floor gang
that's what that stands for nothing it's
a test there's more gates does that mean
more passwords oh [ __ ] look sir Avena
hotel that's gotta be it [ __ ] fed didn't
[ __ ] add Debbie okay
let's find a way past this [ __ ] fedra
gate very creative gets right to the
point
this isn't let's go let's go fast
oh that you skate too it's crossed out
no way it isn't five three four five do
you know the code
yes no what I found has a bunch of them
but we need to get power to the gate
first okay all right all right let's
gank this [ __ ] hey they need
soup yeah it's not a gas yeah mother
[ __ ] way here again can you pee in
there oh [ __ ] no what the don't mention
that there's gas in the courthouse
garage and the dome alright
courthouse garage in the dome so what's
the plan for finding these places we
ride around and see what we see
I can't go back here can i he did have
to climb back Kent
then what am i doing
I can climb this right otherwise this I
can't climb this excuse me all right
let's check out here oh it's up in here
okay the dome I assumed the dome don't
shoot it alley it's kind of cool
that's the dome damn look at this [ __ ]
pretty sure we're here nice Wow
[Music]
and the dome it's straight ahead
interesting
look at this [ __ ] the military bomb
sometimes destroy parts of the city that
would look at the Saxons like well it
usually worked on the infected ward it
off oh ration distribution center in
Boston
we'd line up for blocks and the food
sucked I go crazy some people did come
on let's find a way in
alright alright alright alright alright
alright alright
[Music]
nothing there thanks for being useless
Oh legs off we're gonna shoot that shoot
it's worth exploring out there okay
we'll do it after then all right I got
you
alright she's not so bad see they never
check first it's so funny to me
should I toss the thing at him it's only
two of them right can you turn around
and have your diarrhea somewhere else
please I'm not testing how well they can
see me in the grass
oh you can't kind of see me
okay now's the time to strike uno dos
tres cuatro Cinco Cinco do de shiran
here she can't hear I'm so quiet nice
nice yes yes yes yes dude all right I
got an idea what if it turns out Joel
was Jojo and he was he was packing
magazines under his shirt so he actually
didn't take any damage even though it
looked like it was dead but but Jojo and
Jojo Joel have similar names and they're
both smart and epic oh [ __ ] so maybe
joel is alive and that's the plot twist
and that's why you know I mean Buster's
my theory and I like that there a lot so
I'm just gonna stick with that Joel is
alive and he's packing magazines under
his shirt anyone yes but he was hit in
the head
you can pack magazines in the head never
done that crunch oh no
[Music]
you don't sound so good
there's some thick grass boy seven
stages of grief that's funny
should we take these guys out and can
you progress with that let's try with
that if we don't look at them and they
can't see us
oh this grass stinks I'm uh I'm floor
again come on they can't see me
yeah floor gang there's nothing here
later [ __ ]
[Music]
what is happening oh they can still see
me they can't climb right that's their
thing that's the rules of this universe
of sight
whoa cool place legs broken we just
leave Deena
good good Hey Ellie and I made some
money okay let's uh motor how can you
tell one there are menorah decorations
on the wall it's a Jewish thing and - I
didn't burst into flames just now so
burst into flames it's just a dumb joke
well unlike your other ones you oh boy
this place I don't get it a lot of
memories my sister used to drag me to a
synagogue all the time why would she
barking the flames never struck me as
much of a believer yeah I like coming
from a long line of survivors
you mean after outbreak day that and the
Inquisition and the Holocaust my family
always made it out alive barely
okay we're going in here let's put on
the flashlight yeah
number we he's serious I can move this
we this is open from this side maybe I
supposed to pull it out won't fit
through Oh miss some ammo thanks guys
but we can use it to get over there okay
damn she's strong
ow 20% on the gas we got the gas god
damn it hey language I was feeling this
is not it's empty house sucks why would
you close it again we'll try our luck at
the courthouse garage let's get out of
here
huh yeah
you made me dinner oh thank you I'll
wait a little bit
thank you what time is it
oh well it's almost hey maybe I should
wrap it up we'll play a little bit more
found that dinner yet so we did all that
to find out we didn't have gas I can in
now it's too much of a bummer
also now it opens convenient do you
still pray sometimes
sometimes I just say little ones do
myself
aren't you little quirky yeah while I do
all the work now I'm not talking to any
more I'm sick of it this way oh yeah all
right dear private Miller
we got fresh intel there there's an
active WTF hideout grab available
soldiers execute any suspects secure the
location and await my arrival another
place to check out I suppose it's this
oh this is the Torah the what that's
Scripture it's like a like a Jewish
Bible hmm my sister would have flipped
for this the one we used in New Mexico
was half burnt are those really old
they're something all right well at
least I didn't just chuck everything why
are we doing this what are we looking
for I guess we got ammo hmm hey what are
you doing
shortcut to the other balcony with this
okay Ellie careful [ __ ] she's crazy
well look at that ceiling hold r1 and
say look at the ceiling right so cool
yeah you could have jumped with a little
bit of something you know I'm not gonna
jump up now you okay I'm not are you
serious why did the game tell me this
game one that likes to [ __ ] with you'd
say get out of my way oh my god what the
[ __ ]
slowly becoming ceiling gang no swing
[ __ ] get the bling [ __ ]
yeah this is cool yeah yeah how hard can
we go one more one more one more for the
ceiling yeah I'm still in gang now I
changed my mind
alright we're done here ain't looking
anymore
God forgive me
okay across the dome off the list you're
against Mergen in the courthouse
Jurgens [ __ ] you tell me after
we leave
Hey
all right gamers we're gonna impart to
their thank you for joining he's full
out here at least this life's weird
being in accuse II and not hearing
trucks thanks for being patient with
that technicalities appreciate it and
that was probably you're not too bummed
out I don't know what else to say just
got more and more pair yeah
all right I get it um I wish I could
stay longer but there will be another
one tomorrow all right
20% muscle crease thanks for all the new
subs appreciate you guys I'm gonna go
haven't been there thanks for joining
that was fun bye bye hey dole ro face